let's take a few more call 617 830 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 757
area code while there from 757 of what's
your name and where you're calling from
our nishant to talk about gerrymandering
all right go ahead eat as I saw your
interview with a bill Olga V yeah and I
thought it was very good but the thing
was when you try to resolve
gerrymandering they try to resolve it
with dual parties but they're still
drawing singer their districts so the
problem is still there now the solution
I would like to suggest is the one
that's fair vote org suggestion which is
making like three feet super districts
and that way the party that still earns
the most votes still get some more
sheets right so what if I to explain to
the audience a little bit about what how
that works correct me if i'm wrong i
believe the way that would work is
ideally you still have a neutral
committee draw the regular district so
to speak but then you have super
districts which are based on the results
of groups of districts and that way the
drawing of individual districts can be
has less of a political influence is
that more or less the way they proposed
it it's more it's more like you get one
district but you get three sheets i
think and yeah the implosion that I
think you're absolutely spot on that and
bill bill old oglesby said this which is
no matter what because of the
urban-rural divide between liberals and
conservatives even in a fairer a more
fair scenario you're still unlikely to
have results that actually mirror the
political divide within the state so you
can sort of come up with methods that
would be better and the one you're
suggesting is interesting I've read
about at one site I don't know obviously
all of the details of it but I'm going
to check it out in more detail
appreciate that
great idea yes I everyone check out fair
vote org all right thank you very much
we will check that out on that note
let's take a break we are taking calls
at 6 1 7 830 4750 we will take more
calls after the break